[Music]
this undivided substance of absolute
freedom ascends the throne of the world
without any power being able to resist
it for since in truth consciousness
alone as the element in which the
spiritual beings or powers have their
substance their entire system which is
organized and maintained by division
into masses or spheres has collapsed
now that the individual consciousness
conceives the object as having no other
essence than self-consciousness itself
or as being absolutely notion what made
the notion into an existent object was
its direction into separate subsistence
spheres but when the object becomes an
ocean there is no longer anything in it
with a continuing existence negativity
has permeated all its moments it comes
into existence in such a way that each
individual consciousness raises itself
out of its allotted sphere no longer
finds its essence and its work in this
particular sphere but grasps itself as
the notion of will grasps all spheres as
the essence of this will and therefore
it can only realize itself in a work
which is a work of the whole in this
absolute freedom therefore all social
groups or classes which are the
spiritual spheres into which the whole
is articulated are abolished the
individual consciousness that belong to
any such sphere and willed and fulfilled
itself in it has put aside its
limitation its purpose is the general
purpose its language universal law its
work the universal work
paragraph 585 continues higgles
examination of this notion and I do mean
notion both in the the broader sense
that we typically use it and in a very
specific sense that the gift that that
Hagel has in mind the notion of will and
in particular that of the general will
and the relationship of the individual
to the general will within a society
within in particular here French society
of leading up to the revolution and and
through the revolution brought about by
the Enlightenment so this this idea this
this concept of general will here he's
going to talk about that in terms of the
substance of absolute freedom the
absolute freedom of the title of this
this very section right that is what is
being explored here how does this
permeate the society how does it
transform it and we can talk in terms of
real changes that is changes that are
observable that impact the the vir click
the actual and we can also talk in terms
of ideal changes as well and these don't
always map on to each other so we want
to keep that in mind as we're reading
about these transformations that are
taking place within this section so
let's take a look at the text he tells
us this undivided substance of absolute
freedom ascends the throne of the world
without any power being able to resist
it so now we have something that stands
out as similar to the lord of the world
in the earlier discussions that that we
we saw in both the reason section and in
the self consciousness section also it
came up again in the spirit section
earlier on and nothing is
able to oppose it why is nothing able to
oppose it because anything opposing it
in the name of some sort of universality
is really opposing it as a particularity
opposed to the universal so let's jump
ahead a little bit and then we'll come
back to the text Hegel here is
contrasting this absolute freedom the
general will against all of thee as he's
going to call it in this section
spiritual beings and powers or as he
called it just earlier and again
reaffirms in this section spiritual
masses or spheres domains areas estates
whatever we want to call them factions
perhaps within a society every single
one of them in a way has a sort of
universality to it it presents itself at
least to those who belong to it as if it
is somehow absolutely central the tasks
that it is occupied with the values that
it is preoccupied with and trying to
realize those should matter to everybody
and we get a kind of myopia a kind of
blindsided neskowin
that that occurs with us so a doctor for
example you know working in his hospital
thinks that healing people is the most
important thing and everything else
should be subservient to that the
engineer working in her context believes
that the product that she is designing
and perhaps even you know expanding the
range of human activity through that's
the most important thing the person in
charge of education I mean if you've
ever been to a college professors and
administrators think that they're doing
the most important thing in the world
and and everybody does this so everybody
is bringing some sort of not necessarily
universe iliza beliefs tending to be
universal in importance in essence in
and you know the the Vaes and basically
what is what is really most
seneschal they're all trying to claim
that and we saw that this leads to all
sorts of conflicts between these
different let's call them social forces
or representatives of social groups
classes dynamics they're always revealed
as not being as universal as they would
like to pretend to be what is universal
the general will the absolute substance
in this case so Hegel goes on and he
says in truth consciousness alone is the
element in which these spiritual beings
or powers have their substance and he
talks about an entire system organized
and maintained by division into masses
or spheres as having collapsed now has
it collapsed in actuality does this mean
that we have attained the classless
society and perhaps even a moneyless
society where nothing is there's no
difference between anybody and we're all
just part of this big general will no
that's that's not the case in actuality
these social classes these these
articulated organized parts of the
system still are there in place I mean
there have been attempts to try to get
away from that one particularly
interesting one that comes to mind for
me is when the Chinese military
attempted for a very brief experiment to
get rid of ranks and to fight against in
this case the the Vietnamese with units
that didn't actually have leaders it
went terrible you do in fact need some
sort of structure but ideally what does
that mean ideally in the realm of the
mind which doesn't just include oh you
know each person isolated by themselves
in the world of ideas and ideas are
public by this point this this
distinction has been abolished
because a very important point how does
it get abolished
well because consciousness permeates all
of this all of these spiritual masses
and spheres something may have been done
according to tradition according to
routine according to you know the SOP
standard operating procedures for a long
time and then somebody comes along and
says well wait a second why are we doing
it that way why does this person just
sit over there stamping things on their
desk and this guy busts his butt over
here working to make up for you know
what this person over here isn't doing
these are inefficient what's going on
here this is part of what happens during
the French Revolution and indeed other
revolutions as well it's also what
happens when we're engaged in what we
call you know these days innovation or
disruption all right
something consciousness permeates a
system that's already in place and the
individuals who are part of it start
saying well wait a second why don't I
get a voice why why are you the one who
decides the way the institutional
culture goes maybe we should be using
this operating system instead of this
antiquated one that you have maybe these
fillable forms that you have are
actually crap which turns out to be the
case quite often let's make some new
fillable forms and let's actually
rethink what we're doing with them so
that the things that the data that
people are entering actually goes
somewhere and make sense all of that is
along the lines of what Hegel is talking
about here all of that is not only real
transformation but ideal transformation
so going back to the text he says this
entire system which is organized and
maintained by division into masses or
spheres is collapsed now that the
individual consciousness conceives the
object as having no other essence then
self consciousness itself or as being
absolutely notion and you know being
absolutely notion means that there's a
sort of calm
pensive grasp right of one's own
involvement in it what is all this talk
mean it means that these individuals
down here start to become demystified
about the the nature and the importance
of these spiritual masses they start
saying wait a second I have a stake I
matter in this because I am part of this
general will I represent this general
well better than the people running
these spheres do they're just motivated
by particular interests or ideologies or
old ways of doing things
habits you might say on an institutional
scale people start saying why don't we
put this to a vote why don't we try this
why don't we change who is in charge
all right so Hegel says this is a little
bit of metaphysics here we could call it
metaphysics of society what made the
notion into an existent object was its
direction and two separate subsistence
spheres but when the object becomes an
ocean there's no longer anything in it
with a continuing existence negativity
has permeated all of its moments what
does this mean to say negativity has
permeated all of its moments this means
that the moments still do exist the the
spiritual masses and spheres still are
there but at every place there's
somebody who could critique who could
say wait a second
this isn't right this needs to change
you know they could also say oh this is
really wonderful we should do more and
more of this although that's less often
the case when critique is going on isn't
it and so Hegel here is mapping you
could say the development of
consciousness through the notion onto
the transformations of society now we're
starting to see real transformation
we're only ideal transformations were
taking place he says it comes now what's
the it here
the notion it comes into existence in
such a way that each individual
consciousness raises itself out of its
allotted sphere no longer finds its
essence and work in this particular
sphere but grasps itself as the notion
of will so why do I have this sort of
three-part schema here substance
absolute freedom the general will at the
top individuals down below spiritual
masses and spheres mediating in between
well because in the past these spiritual
masses or spheres or powers whatever you
want to call them were indeed mediating
for the individuals who are members of
those who are part of its fabric but
each of those individuals is a human
being a consciousness a rational self
consciousness at least in possibility
some people may be so broken so beaten
down that they can't conceive of
themselves as anything other than a cog
in the wheel or as a part of this
particular estate I'm only a peasant I
till the field I keep my mouth shut in
my head down and that's that or I am a
noble you know I continue on my family's
line manage the estate show up to war
when called upon go to events that that
hopefully at least maintain if not
increased my social status and try not
to be ruined
by all the creditors hounding me and we
could go on and on and on people often
conceive of themselves as just what they
are within the context of their social
role which is given to them as part of
this spiritual sphere they belong to
this I am a university professor I am
only here to transmit the wisdom of the
ages or to you know pick another mission
to you know open up new minds to old
vistas
or to revolutionize the masses by by
unmasking the ideology pick whatever you
like so long as you're thinking of
yourself as just what you are with you
know in in relation to your sphere
you're not really thinking of yourself
as a full free consciousness and what is
the notion that allows us to break
through that it's the notion of will the
notion of choice the notion of
self-determination and as we saw in the
previous paragraph this is intimately
connected with the concept of
personality so insofar as each
individual and I'm just picking on one
individual here grasps itself through
the notion of will it grasps itself as
something that transcends the state the
the the the class the race the whatever
it happens to be that it's divided into
and when I say yet I mean the totality
of the society the individual is not
divided the individual is subsumed into
that but insofar as they grasp themself
through this notion of will not just as
their own will but as the general will
they transcend that so he goes he says
it grafts itself as the notion of will
grasps all spheres as the essence of
this will and therefore can only realize
itself in a work which is a work of the
whole so you still do remain the factory
worker part of this group you still do
remain the manager you still do remain
the high school teacher you still do
remain the subway train conductor or
janitor or pick whatever you like but
now your work is contributing to the
totality in part because the spiritual
master you belong to is itself supposed
to be contributing to the totality
something that's being left off here
well wait a second what if your
spiritual mass the
you belong to is not really contributing
to the totality what if instead it is
parasitical it is drawing upon the
resources of the totality and enjoying
them and consuming them but not really
giving anything back even though it
might be saying that it's giving
something back was that the case in the
French Revolution it certainly was for
those who don't know the French
Revolution takes place essentially as a
bourgeois but also harnessing the people
in certain areas a bourgeois revolution
against the upper classes and what were
the upper or privileged classes in that
case of course you have the king at the
top but the king is really his own thing
and he's also then surrounded by a whole
bunch of courtiers but then you've got
the nobles and the nobles have become
part of this courtier class why because
otherwise they're too prone to engage in
rebellions so you know louis xiv for
example concentrates his court by
bringing the nobles out of the menses
and saying you have to attend a court
right and then we've also got the second
estate the clergy and some of the clergy
are dirt poor right the people who are
parish priests just making it you know
ministering to people but we've got
these the whole strata of society of
people who are you know quite rich and
you know this still goes on within
pretty much every religious organization
you can find today because it goes on
within pretty much any organization you
can find today it's not a uniquely
religious thing
now what is it that the nobles are
supposed to be contributing are they
merely supposed to be ornaments in the
crown of the king that doesn't seem like
a very good reason to throw a ton of
money at them does it
or resources or time or privileges what
are the nobles actually good for in the
past the understanding was the nobles
become the nobles precisely because in
time of war they're supposed to be
called upon to lead and to fight and to
save the nation and you know in the past
quite often that that did occur it's
worth mentioning as well that around the
time of the French Revolution you know
we often have this really silly
caricature of the French because of
world war ii or like ah you know there's
so weak they they they lost you know
against the the Nazis they couldn't
really fight you know we had to come in
and save them and then we had to do the
same thing in Vietnam although we don't
talk that much about that because we
also lost in Vietnam as well at this
point in time the French were really the
holy terror of Europe I mean the other
the other you know really dangerous
element in the centuries before that was
the Spanish of course right and the
Germans were seen as kind of a weak
group you know up until the time after
the Napoleonic Wars that's a little bit
of a side note so the nobles were
supposed to be contributing in some way
but they don't actually contribute who's
doing the main fighting in modern
warfare and we are talking about modern
warfare in the 1700s it's there you know
there are officers leading but it's
primarily masses of troops shooting at
each other
artillery men cavalry the nobles have
really outworn their use they no longer
contribute to the society what about the
clergy you know the traditional division
within medieval society was the peasants
cultivate the land and produce food the
nobles protect and what are the priests
do they pray priests monks nuns they
provide guidance they were the first
teachers in
many respects they're the ones who kept
Western civilization in it's literate
form alive at a time when during what we
call the Dark Ages which were you know
just a few centuries everyone also is
losing it in the West do they really
serve that purpose anymore do you need
people praying for you or is that a
matter of superstition that the
Enlightenment now has cast aside do you
need them teaching don't you already
have other people doing that we could
also ask about the administrative
bureaucracy the French distinguished
between the noblesse to pay the nobles
of the sword and the noblesse to the
robe the what we might call bureaucratic
nobility the those who serve the king
and the instrumentalities of the kingdom
by pushing papers by exercising judgment
by making decisions they will be
retained those are still serving a very
vital purpose so during the French
Revolution if we're thinking about
Hegel's discussion here each of these
spiritual masses or spheres is supposed
to be in a non parasitical but rather
productive contributory way making its
own you know share of the general will
so institutions or organizations or
people who are not contributing are
going to be fluffed off this is a
prefiguration of the terror let's come
back to the text now so he says it
grasps all the spheres is the essence of
this will and therefore can only realize
itself any work which is a work of the
whole things goes on he says in this
absolute freedom therefore all social
groups or classes which are the
spiritual spheres into which the whole
is articulated are abolished now
they abolished in reality only much much
later and they're never truly abolished
because you can't completely overcome
differentiation but they are abolished
in you might say in the realm of ideas
by proclaiming for example the Equality
of all people although the French you
know of course did say all men before
the law or you know in proclaiming that
education would henceforth for men this
is why Mary Wollstonecraft wrote her
vindication of the rights of women
the total side topic there but worth
noting all men would receive a free
public education you sort of a leveling
of the playing field
ideally not in actuality not completely
in actuality we should say but ideally
so these spheres are being abolished
insofar as their their importance lies
in in this this schema so he says the
individual consciousness that belong to
any such sphere is also being abolished
so if you think of yourself as just a
candlestick maker or just a servant or
just a bureaucratic functionary or
whatever it happens to be I'm just this
then you're going to be left behind you
have to be somehow connected to this
general will and that is through the
notion of will so Hegel closes this
paragraph in a very interesting way by
saying the individual consciousness that
belong to any sphere and willed and
fulfilled itself in it has now put aside
this limitation candlestick makers
become conscious of themselves as
members of the nation as in some sense
equal to the nobles equal to the judges
equal to the clergy equal to whoever
that has enjoyed the privileges up until
this point notice how he brings us to an
end here its purpose
what's purpose the purpose of the
individual who
become conscious in this sense its
purpose is the general purpose its
language universal law its work the
universal work so there's a kind of
overcoming of particularity not
happening through these but happening at
the level of individual by becoming
identified with by becoming a part of
the substance of absolute freedom the
general will
you